- All right, Lucy.
If you want this, will you please speak?
Wow, she doesn't want it.
(video game music)
This is Lucille Blue, aka Lucy.
- [Woman] This is Bob Segar.
- [Woman] My dog's name is Manny.
- Lucy's a lady on the street,
but a freak in the dog park.
- He also sort of doesn't love other dogs.
He's more indifferent towards them
unless he wants to hump them.
- Manny is a chihuahua mix,
but we don't know what the mix is.
- Lucy's favorite toy is a ball.
She loves chasing balls, she's very fast.
She's got long legs like a model.
- He's had this decapitated squirrel
for about five or six
years that he just like...
He loves them to death?
- We don't have any
squeaky toys in our house
because my husband
hates the sound of them,
so he's only allowed
really boring plush toys
shaped like rats.
(video game music)
- Lucy, this is a box for you.
Do you want to open it?
Should we open it?
Ahhh, a Chuckit!
Do you know what those are?
Does that look like...
Oh, yeah.
So, you're already ready to play.
Yeah, get it.
- I think he loves the orange.
- Ohhhh.
Ohhhh! Look at that!
- Yeah, this is really weird
that he's playing with balls,
but this is how he acts
when he plays with toys.
It's quite aggressive.
(bouncing)
- Well, you missed it.
- Yeah, I think this
is the most responsive
that he's ever been to a ball.
This is a really good toy for Lucy
because she loves balls.
She's a lady but she loves balls.
- Ohhh.
What's in this one?
The other one was so fun.
- Open it yourself.
Open it yourself.
We're working on it, she can't do it yet.
(playful, energizing music)
- (laughs) He's very shocked.
- Oh my gosh, it's
a bear.
Okay.
- Who is this?
Is this your new best friend?
Yes, it is.
(thudding)
What is this thing?
Is it a monkey or a bear?
- It's just the squeaking sounds like
the cries of a dying animal,
and she loves that.
- He is just ripping
the face off this one.
- She wants to rip it apart so
she's gotta get it real wet.
Wet bears, easier to rip apart.
Yeah, wow.
You're doing a good job.
Rippin', rippin'.
What's in there?
- More balls?
(playful music)
(laughing)
(thudding)
- Okay, she did get it out.
(thudding and rolling)
- (laughs) Now he's into it.
- I'm not excited about this one.
It's gonna be squeaky and annoying.
(squeaking)
(bouncing)
- This is the equivalent to
buying your child a drum set.
Lucy, oh my god.
(squeaking)
- He doesn't seem as interested.
He doesn't wanna sit for it.
If he really wants something,
he'll actually sit down for it.
- Lucy ranks these balls 12 out of 10.
But, Mommy wants to throw them away.
Open it.
(video game music)
Lucy, you gotta start from the middle.
That's where it opens.
- Oh my god.
It's got a hit in the box.
- Oh, you have one of these.
- Ah, you're doing a good job!
You actually opened that one!
- He likes it when it's
got peanut butter in it.
- You put treats or peanut butter in here
and this toy currently does not
have treats or peanut butter.
- I'm gonna try to put a treat in this
and see if he'll get it out.
Eeww, I hate this.
- She's like, "This is some bullshit.
"Umm, usually there's
peanut butter in here?
"I think this one's defective."
I think that's what she's thinking.
- He's like, "Where's the peanut butter?"
(laughing)
- I think it's too big for Manny.
It's literally the size of his head.
Manny, this box is bigger than you!
Man, I could fit him in the box.
- All right, she's got it now.
She's into the boxes.
- It sounds big and fluffy.
- This is gonna get so
soggy when he chews it.
- Oh man, and it squeaks. (laughs)
He just wants to take it away.
- If you want this, speak.
(barking)
Okay. (laughs)
(growling)
- It's kind of nice, it's
like he's got a friend,
'cause it's so big.
- It says, "Ideal for gentle chewers,"
and Lucy
I don't think is the gentlest.
- I don't get this.
I mean, maybe he gets it.
- Out of the top five Amazon dog toys,
I think Segar likes this one the best.
I can definitely see Segar
snuggling with this at night,
waking me up in the morning with it
pressing against my face,
carrying it up and down the stairs.
He's gonna be really happy, I think.
- I think this is Manny's favorite toy.
I think the ball was my favorite toy,
but this is definitely Manny's favorite.
- All right, Lucy's
favorite were these balls,
because... (sighs)
(squeaking)
Well, that's...
That's why.
(playful music)
(swishing)
(creaking)